a good example of collaborationists look
at the International Space Station the
International Space Station is arguably
one of the most complex complicated
structures ever built it's bigger than a
football field if it was on the earth
will weigh about a million pounds it is
an amazing orbiting research facility
and it was built in space by 15 nations
some of these nations were not always
the best of friends in some cases they
were on opposite sides of the Cold War
and opposite opposite sides of the space
race and what enabled this to happen in
space what enabled this construction
project what neighbor labeled this
amazing accomplishment of humanity was
the willingness to set aside our
differences and work together towards a
common goal and what we did is we found
something that we agreed on in this
particular case space exploration and we
decided to work through that and what
developed is personal relationships
people got to know each other they got
to see that their hopes and dreams and
their motivation for being in the space
program and being in the space business
were the same and through those personal
relationships trust developed and
through that trust that's that trust
that was built through those personal
relationships enabled the program to
weather the storms to whether the anesh
the eventual bumps in the road then the
crises that occurred and I think that is
a that is a really good lesson that we
can apply we can take the lesson that
built the International Space Station
and bring it down to earth we could put
it in the context of our rapidly
developing hyper interconnected global
society and realize that we can do
amazing things here on earth by applying
that same level of collaboration I think
the secret sauce if you will was to seek
the low-hanging fruit seek those things
that we do agree on and use that to
build relationships and to build the
platform through which we can then start
to address the things that we don't
agree on
you